so they're here the long-awaited covid
vaccines and they're up to 95
effective the hard work's done all we
need to do now is inject them right
well that's a lot easier said than done
we have a vaccine so it's very good news
how can we roll that out how effective
is that going to be
help is on its way we can now see the
way out
so who gets it first it'll be the most
vulnerable in our society
healthcare workers care workers and
people over the age of 80
then it'll be people in the 70s then 60s
then 50s and finally the rest of the
population
we are suggesting that vaccines are
offered in order to protect people who
are most at risk of
dying from covet 19 as well as to
protect
health and social care services because
by doing so
we also protect lives the only people
who won't get the vaccine
are pregnant women and most children
that's because there's not enough data
for those with a baby on the way
and most children are at mild risk from
the disease
you could be waiting a while for your
vaccine though the nhs hopes to immunize
1 million people a week but it could be
the middle of 2021 at the earliest for
most of us
so where will we get the jab well
there'll be a combination of three
modes of delivery hospitals mass
vaccination centers
and gps or pharmacists this stadium in
derby
is one example of a mass distribution
center it's been taken
over by the government for distribution
so to get the vaccine you might have to
come to stadiums or sports halls like
this
in cities around the country or maybe to
one of the 50 hospital hubs
set up to store vaccines around the
country
but some of the more easily distributed
vaccines will also be offered at
local gp surgeries and all of the
vaccines will need
two doses a few weeks apart
while it's true the hardest work is done
distributing the vaccines is going to be
one
big logistical challenge you mentioned
the minor 70 conditions
that it needs to be stored in so this is
a challenging rollout
the fisa vaccine will be the hardest to
distribute because it has to be stored
at
minus 70 degrees celsius for comparison
most freezers sit at around minus 18 to
minus 30 degrees
on top of that the vaccine must be used
within five days of being moved to a
fridge
that's not an optional best before date
it's use it or lose it
and while it's effective at protecting
against the virus it's
really expensive the other two vaccines
are much more practical
the astrazeneca vaccine that doesn't
have these uh cold storage requirements
and so is is operationally easier to
roll out
moderna's can be stored at normal
freezer temperatures of minus 20 degrees
for up to six
months and best of all the oxford
vaccine can be stored
in the fridge the oxford vaccine is also
the cheapest of the three
in fact it costs the same as a cup of
coffee
the final hurdle for a vaccine is
psychological how do you get people to
have it
a study in september 2020 found that
only half of britain
say they would definitely take the jab
almost a fifth
say they would refuse it in all
circumstances
so how do you convince people to take it
vaccine deniers and the the people who
are generally
suspicious of vaccines will always be
there
but i think the the nature of the
pandemic
first in a lifetime remember is such
that most people will recognize that
this is the way
you're likely to be able to control it
all three vaccines are more effective
than the flu jab
but people are more trusting the flu
vaccine older people especially
so despite clinical trials showing the
vaccines are safe
some kind of public information campaign
will be needed
to encourage people to take them or it
could be pressure from the private
sector
with some companies refusing the general
public without proof of the vaccine
we are looking at changing our terms and
conditions to say
for international travelers that we will
ask people to have a vaccination before
they can get on the aircraft
the fastest vaccine ever made until now
took four years so for there to be safe
and effective covered vaccines within 12
months is nothing short of
extraordinary but with 50 million
people in the queue in the uk alone it
could be a while before you get the jab
that could get us all back to normal
you